if you look back over the course of
American history we've been through many
periods of polarization to some extent I
think the period from the 1950s through
the 1960s was unusual in that the degree
of partisan polarization was much less
than normal but if you go back and look
at American politics in the 19th century
and in much of the early 20th century
you find that in fact you know there
were very sharp differences between the
parties and very intense conflict and
very overheated rhetoric and really
nasty personal attacks on even some of
the leaders that we've come to think of
as among our greatest you know
presidents people like Thomas Jefferson
and Abraham Lincoln were viciously
attacked Franklin Roosevelt certainly
was as well so in a way this is just
sort of normal politics it's really
interesting to go back and of course
they didn't have the internet or cable
news or talk radio but what they had
were pamphlets and party newspapers and
if you go back and look at some of those
things you know as I said the the
attacks were very personal very nasty I
mean much worse than anything you know
we've seen in recent election campaigns
you